Rishi sunak has reached a significant
number
178 MPS publicly backing the formula
former Chancellor to become the next
leader of the conservative party and the
country's next prime minister our
political correspondent Liz Bates is
with me now and this number is
significant Liz because this is the
majority of the Parliamentary party it
is 357 conservative MPS Rishi Cena has
been racking up numbers rapidly over the
last couple of days he's finally got to
this 178 number what that really does is
I think pile a lot of political pressure
on pennymord and especially in the wake
of um Boris Johnson's statement last
night he was pulling the part in unity a
lot of conservative MPS have been
speaking during this very short campaign
about the fact that they've just come
off the back of another conservative
leadership campaign it's been a very
very divisive period they need to come
together that's why this campaign was so
short in the first place so the pressure
will mount on her just purely because
he's reached this number he has
yeah I mean this is all pressure
building on Penny modern but the the
thing to remember is
um there are 357 MP so that leaves uh
still the other half of the party their
support is still up for grabs I think
it's going to be really difficult for
Penny Warden to get to that 100 100
Threshold at this point but as you can
see the math is very clear she can still
do it she's only on 25 at the moment but
they are the people that are backing her
publicly do not discount the number of
people in the conservative party that
really don't want to see Rishi sunak in
number 10 so there's still a possibility
here and speaking to Penny Morton's team
they are suggesting that she wants to
continue